We're going to start with a very natural real
world problem and then I'm going to explain to
you a very different problem in pure mathematics
that surprisingly solves this real world problem.
You want to buy something on
the internet. So here's you
and here is this online store; and between
you is this channel we all know and love
called the internet. But the internet is a
little bit of a noisy channel, so say if you
want to buy something from this store you might
want to send the store 16 numbers - your credit
card. So like 8352 - whatever - 9115.
- (Brady: That's not your credit card?)
- That's not my credit card. But you want to send
16 numbers over the internet to this store. Or
maybe somebody else is sending 16 numbers and
say that your credit card number is 8351...9115
You really don't want the store to receive your
credit card number by mistake instead of somebody
else's credit card and charge you. So you want to
some way build in redundancy in the way that you
send these numbers so that if there's an error
you can first: figure out that there's an error,
don't charge the wrong person; and second of
all maybe correct that error, you mighthope.
(I've heard of this, this is errorcorrection.)
- This is error correction - I'm going to
explain to you one of the uh first beautiful
examples of an error correcting code. Before
we do beautiful examples let's just say,
what is the most naive thing you could do?
How could you use redundancy to be able
to detect when errors occur - any ideas?
(I would imagine-
I would imagine sending it twice)
- Oh yeah, send the numbers multiple
times. So if I had this sequence and I sent
them multiple times I would send 88335522...
1155. Okay, send each number twice so now if one
error occurs here I say aha I was expecting each
pair to be equal and here's a pair that's
not equal, so error. And now I know. But
that doesn't let me correct the error because
I don't know which was right, 2 or 1. So of
course if I wanted to correct it: send each one
three times. So if I send each one three times
um I'll be able to correct the errors. Let me
just write that down: 888-333 - I'm actually
writing this down for a reason - uh it's it's
it's a lot more numbers right. So if this one
becomes a 1 now I know it should be a 2 because 2
was the was the most common answer in that triple.
But you'll see that this is two times the amount
of numbers, or three times the amount of numbers.
And nobody wants to sit on their browser uh
and wait a long time to make a credit card
transaction because you had to send way more
numbers; it's unwieldy. So we want a much more
efficient way to build in redundancy to solve
this problem. Okay I think I want a new sheet.
Well before I tell you a nice way to solve this
problem, uh now we're going to switch to a totally
different problem in pure mathematics. Imagine
that you have a collection of random points. So
you could think about these points in the (x,y)
plane; so each of these has an x coordinate
and a y coordinate. When I have this random
collection of points what I want to do with
it is I want to thread a curve- thread a curve
through this collection of points. And as you
can see what I did I really wanted my curve to
exactly pass through each one of these points;
it's not something statistical, I actually wanted
to pass through each one of those points. And when
I have one of these curves that threads through
the points I'll say that this curve interpolates
those points. So the main question that you want
to understand for interpolation is how complicated
does this interpolating curve have to be? So you
might imagine right if I have more and more random
points, if I want a curve that has to exactly pass
through all those points, each time it has to hit
a new point it maybe has to twist a little bit or
turn or move. So it has to get more complicated
as the number of points grows.
- (I intuitively know)
(what you mean by complicated but is
there a proper definition of complicated?)
- We're getting there, we're getting there. So um
so exactly for that reason that I want to quantify
this I'm going to switch this problem around and
I'm going to turn it on a head and I'm going to
say that I fix some type of curve - and I know
this is still very abstract but we're about to
do examples. So fix some type of curve and once
I fix this I've fixed how complicated this curve
is already. And then what I ask is, what is the
maximum number of random points it interpolates?
So I've just flipped the problem on its head.
Fix the curve and then say, given how complicated
that curve is, does it have the flexibility
to pass through how many types of points?
Should we do some examples? Let's do the
first example; let's suppose I gave you
two points. So what's the least complicated
type of curve that you can think of that
interpolates two points? (A straight line)
- A straight line definitely. So yes, a line
always interpolates two points but if I were
to give you three points - and remember I want
my points to be random - they probably won't lie
on a line. So 2 is the maximum number of points
that a line interpolates. Okay? So now-
- (I thought a line)
(would- I thought a line actually covers
an infinite number of points but-)
- Oh very very good, very good point, it does
cover infinitely many points. You can imagine I
can put some other points onto this line but these
are now not random. And remember then in our main
problem we very judiciously required them to be
random points. One way you can think about it is
take the points that are on the line and just
imagine bumping them all in random directions.
If I were to bump these in random directions
like there would no longer be a line, right,
it would have to be some sort of twisty curve that
would interpolate all those bumped points. Okay so
that was two points, let's try to do more points.
Next example: let's do three points okay. Any idea
for uh for the simplest type of curve you can
think of that interpolates three points? You can
do it with a circle. So these are very classical
results; of course Euclid knew a line interpolates
two points, he also knew a circle interpolates
three points. And Euclid didn't have equations
for these curves or anything he only had things
you could synthetically construct. So you can
actually construct the circle interpolating three
points - it's not going to look good if I freehand
it. - (Go on let's see ya- let's see your skills)
- Nope, that looked very elliptical.
- (That is that's aterrible circle)
- I could have done a much better job with this,
anyhow. So this was- these are these are two
very classical results that were known to Euclid,
same thing. Three random points, if you have four
random points they won't lie on a circle. Okay so
now I want to describe to you another type
of curve but it's built out of polynomials.
So it's built out of a polynomial f of x - let's
suppose that we first have a linear polynomial,
so a degree 1 polynomial. So let's say this
polynomial is like x plus 2. So when you see
a polynomial like this uh and maybe you think
back to school the first thing you want to do
is you want to start graphing the values of this
polynomial in the (x,y) plane - remember my points
are in the (x, y) plane. Let's see- when I
plug in 0 I get 2, when I plug in 1 I get 3,
when I plug in 2 I get 4 - you see where this is
going - if I plug in any more values I I always
just get the straight line right here and this
curve that I am making for you you is the graph of
this polynomial f of x. I think I'd like another
sheet of paper - I'm sorry I can't write small
Now we're going to do a degree 2 example, so let's
just choose some random polynomial of degree 2
like um x squared minus 4x plus 7. So again I'm
going to graph the the values of this polynomial
in the (x,y) plane. All right so if I plug in
0 I'll get 7, so that's one point on the graph,
if I plug in 1 I'll get 1 minus 4 is minus 3
plus 7 is 4. If I plug in 2 I'll get 4 minus
8 plus 7 - I'll get 3 right. And let's do
another one, let's do 4. If I plug in 4 I'll
get 16 minus 16 plus 7 so I just get 7 again.
So you can see this graph it looks something
like this parabola through those points. So in
both of these two problems uh what I was doing
was I was starting with a polynomial and then
I was getting points on a certain type of curve
which is the graph of a polynomial. So I'm now
going to flip the problem around, this way that
I've set up the interpolation problem, we fix the
type of curve which is the graph of a polynomial
of a certain degree and then we want to know
how many general points does it interpolate.
Okay so this linear case, it's a line, we already
knew how to solve a line - it interpolates two
general points. That means I can specify two
points on here; if I pick any two points I can
always find a linear polynomial so that the graph
of that polynomial interpolates those two points.
And now this has a very explicit description
right; because these points are of the form
some (x value, f of x) what you're trying to do is
you're trying to choose some inputs and then find
a polynomial that maps those to specific outputs.
- (Is it almost like saying what's the minimum
number of points I can have and know
the- ) (know what my thing looks like?)
- It's very related to that. And I- but
I'm asking for a sort of the maximum,
the amount of freedom you have, the maximum
number of points you can have and still have
it lie on such a polynomial. So here you could
do 2 - for degree 2 any guesses for what it is?
It's 3. Um it's sort of like how you went from
a line to a circle except a circle is not a
graph of a polynomial, right, because it fails
the vertical line test. But it's still 3 here.
So you can always do 3; and in fact there's
a general result here, this is called the
Lagrange Interpolation Theorem. So if you're
given n distinct inputs x1 through xn then I
get to choose any outputs, let's say I want to
send x1 to y1 all the way up through xn to yn,
any outputs. Then there is a unique
polynomial f of x of degree n minus 1
such that it accomplishes this. It sends
x1 to y1 and all the way up through xn
to yn. This is the thing that's going to
solve our problem from the very beginning.
Here's our problem from the very beginning - so
remember we're starting with 16 numbers and I
think I'd like to not use specific numbers
for these, I'd like to give them names,
think think of them as variables so I'm going
to call them a1, a2 all the way up through a15,
a16. So here's the key Insight that allows
us to make this error correcting code,
and these codes are called Reed-Solomon codes.
So this was Reed and Solomon's insight is to
encode these 16 numbers a1, a2 up through
a15, a16 as the coefficients of a degree 15
polynomial. So I use these numbers to make a
polynomial, f of x equals a1x to the 15 plus
a2x to the 14 plus plus a15x plus a16. Okay? So
same data, nothing has changed I still- it's just
the data of these 16 numbers.
- (What does that curve)
(look like?)
- Exactly, that's what we have to do. So let's
let's graph this curve. So if we were to graph
this curve- okay this is- I've- this is totally uh
I'm just gonna - this will just be a schematic.
But you imagine there's some graph of this
f of x. And what the Lagrange interpolation
theorem tells us is that if I know just the
value of this polynomial at 16 different
inputs, so like x1 I know it's value,
at some other point x2 I know its value, all the
way 16 points on here - that uniquely determines
the polynomial for me. It's the same data
as knowing its value at 16 different points.
So if you're over here trying to send this
information online; if you want to send this
it's exactly equivalent to sending the values at
16 different points: f of x1 through f of x 16.
So let me come back to this Lagrange interpolation
theorem and let me fill it in a little more. This
n here was really the maximum. So if the points
x1, y1 through xn, yn are random then this n is
actually the max. You can't specify any more values
and still have it lie on the graph of a degree n-1
polynomial. Okay so let's use that fact
to start detecting and correcting errors. Remember
the the thing we have to do is we have to build
in redundancy. And so we don't have redundancy
at the moment where- if we just keep track of
the values at um at 16 points. So let's let's
take this and let's add a little more redundancy;
let's send also the value at just one more point, a
17th point. So we're going to add in one extra
point. Still no problem - it'll be the same degree
15 polynomial whose graph interpolates these
17 points. And notice that these 17 points are
not random; random 17 points would lie on no
graph of a degree 15 polynomial. Okay. But now
the benefit is suppose that there's an error in
transmitting this point. Instead of transmitting
that value I transmit some other value. Now once
that happens this graph goes away; I mean you it
no longer interpolates all of these points because
it doesn't lie on that graph. And now if you think
about it what I have with this collection - not this
one but the erroneous one - these are now 17 points.
And the internet doesn't doesn't have it out to
get you. Okay? It's not it's not sending a specific
really bad choice of a point, it's some random
random error happens in this noisy channel. So
these are a random collection of 17 points which
means that probably there is no- I mean with all
likelihood there is no degree 15 polynomial that
interpolates these 17 points, because 15 is more
than what you get by Lagrange. And so what we have
is we have a way to figure out if there was an
error. Very easy way to figure out that there was
an error, but we don't have a way to correct the
error because we have to know that this point was
the wrong point. If we knew that this was the wrong
point we could leave it out and find the curve
with the other ones; but we don't know that
so well what do we do? Just send one more piece of
data, send its value at an 18th point. So let me add
one more x here. So we're sending one more value; if
we send one more value then we will know that this
is the imposter point because the remaining points
will still be 17 points that lie on the graph of
a degree 15 polynomial which is unexpected.
Lagrange says we should only be able to do
that with with 16 points; and so we can correct our
error. So if you look at this over here, this really
bad way of doing it, you have to send two times
as many points. But using uh Reed-Solomon codes
there's this idea you only have to send one extra
number or you have to send two extra numbers which
is way better than two times the amount of numbers
or three times the amount of numbers.
- (So when I)
(send my credit card details, my 16 numbers, it's-
I'm sending 16 numbers plus two other numbers.)
(Are those two other numbers-)
- To first order. That's
the that's the toy model of what happens, yes
(All right yeah. But like they're not- all these graphs
aren't being plotted by a computer and and mapped)
(and things like that, that's not actually happening?)
- Oh no um it's a it's a very straightforward way
to combine the data of the coefficients and get
the values or to combine the data of the values
and get the coefficients. It's very easy, you don't have
to graph it, the graphing is just what's happening
behind the scenes in the mathematics. And and
let me say it might not seem that impressive
right to 16 numbers - 2 times 16 is uh 32 or 48 and
those aren't that much bigger than 17 or 18. But
this 1 or 2 was independent of the number
of numbers. So like a million, well 2 million
is much bigger, but a million and 1 is not somuch bigger.
- So here's a theorem that I proved
with my collaborator Eric Larson from last year.
A curve of degree d and genus g in R dimensions...